1991 年美國跟伊拉克打完波灣戰爭
空軍一批剛從巴格達炸回來的飛行員
回學校進修空權戰略
他就在那裡教了 3 年
他叫 Robert Pape
現在是芝加哥大學政治學教授
1996 年他出了 Bombing to Win
把二戰到波灣戰爭的空襲一場一場拆開
結論是轟炸很少讓人民起來反政府
反而常讓他們更團結
這是他 10 月 1 號在維吉尼亞州一所大學的演講
講的是美伊戰爭
他說這場仗掀起的變動
要台下這一代來收拾
而下一個用無人機改寫戰局的
可能是台灣
這場美伊戰爭，我把它叫做「升級陷阱」
這個說法，是我在美伊戰爭開戰前幾天提出來的
我寫了一篇文章，放在 Substack 電子報上
我說的升級陷阱，在這次的情況是
動手的是美國跟以色列
他們出手，炸彈命中目標，炸死領導人
今年 2 月 28 號
美國跟以色列開始空襲伊朗
第一波就炸死了伊朗的最高領袖哈米尼
他的權力比總統還大
戰術上成功了，戰略上我們卻變弱了
戰略上一變弱，我們就掉進陷阱了
因為先動手的一方一旦變弱
就得做一個選擇
要不要撤？讓步，宣布勝利然後撤走？
那樣的話，對方已經變強了，就會更強
還是再升級一次？繼續加碼？
過去 7 個多月，我們看到的就是這個陷阱
從開戰到現在，停火、開火來回好幾輪
7 月停火正式破局，美軍重新開炸
10 月初
美國再加派第三艘航空母艦去中東
很遺憾，這種情況還會持續一陣子
大概至少會拖到 1 月，甚至更久
接下來，我要講幾個我所謂的戰略錯誤
他說這些錯，都是最聰明的人才會犯的
第一個是高估懲罰
以為把一個政府炸痛了，它就會垮
開戰那一波炸死的不只最高領袖哈米尼
照他的說法還有半個內閣
擺明了就是要換掉整個政權
根本的問題在於，川普總統在這裡撞上了歷史的重量
歷史的重量
為了換政權而轟炸，從一戰有這種打法開始
從來沒有光靠它推翻過任何一個政府
這話說得很重，但這是我花了 30 年研究的東西
這就是我在教的
這不是隨口說說
這本書講的就是這個
伊朗封住了荷莫茲海峽
那是波斯灣的出海口
全球約兩成石油從這裡過
美國的對策是反過來封鎖伊朗
封鎖跟制裁也是他的老本行
1997 年他就寫過一篇論文
題目叫〈經濟制裁為什麼沒用〉
那封鎖呢？
所以我們就祭出封鎖
預期它會垮掉
美國財長 Scott Bessent 到現在還跟你說它會垮
好，大問題來了
舉一個例子，一個就好，只要一個
我不要你舉 5 個
一戰以來，光靠封鎖就打贏戰爭的，只要一個
不能是封鎖再加上別的轟炸
不能是封鎖加原子彈，那是日本
也不能是封鎖再加上地面部隊占領全國
那是我們對德國做的事
我說的是只有封鎖
我也不是要你舉 3 個月或 6 個月內打贏的例子
我說的是，有史以來
問題就在這裡
我這輩子花了 30 年，研究一戰以來每一場空襲
一戰以來每一次制裁、每一次海上封鎖
這些不是我從哪裡看來的摘要…
寫這些論文的人就是我
第二個錯，是低估伊朗的規模
伊朗的 Shahed 無人機
他形容差不多一張雙人加大床墊大
引擎很陽春，一個月能做好幾百架
打中荷莫茲海峽裡幾艘船
保險費就飆上去
他要台下的學生當負責的將軍
把伊朗 5000 到 7000 架無人機
壓到 200 架以下
我們來看看這個任務有多簡單
每一架無人機，最少能飛的距離
光靠我說的那顆兩缸引擎，不用加裝別的（Shahed-136 用的是四缸引擎）
是 500 英里，這是它的航程，500 英里
40 加侖汽油，就能飛這麼遠
500 英里的縱深，實際上就長這樣
這是以荷莫茲海峽為中心畫出來的
這整塊都是發射區
你得去搜、去找，還得把它們摧毀
這塊地有加州的 1.5 倍大
你大概已經在想，天啊，這也太難了
可是這還不是最糟的
到目前為止，我給你看的還只是平面的問題
無人機很好搬，還能拆開
兩三個人就能輕輕鬆鬆搬來搬去
無人機真正的麻煩，是山
這整塊區域，幾乎全在伊朗的札格羅斯山脈裡
札格羅斯山脈是非常巨大的山
我們換個方式來想
別想無人機，把它想成雙人加大床墊
你得在一棟摩天大樓裡，找出每一張床墊
把一座山想成一棟摩天大樓
那張床墊可能埋在大樓底下的停車場
可能在 1 樓、7 樓、77 樓
這間教室大概放得下幾張？40、50 張吧
可是這只是一棟大樓裡的一個房間，那棟樓有多大？
比帝國大廈高 10 倍
你想想看
那 500 乘 500 英里的範圍，放得下幾棟帝國大廈？
160 萬棟帝國大廈
換個說法，有誰去過曼哈頓？
好，在那 500 乘 500 英里裡，你要搜的是 11,000 個曼哈頓
所以我們為什麼不去做這個任務？
為什麼空軍做不了這件事？
我想你已經看出來了
派陸軍、派 10 萬地面部隊，那又是另一回事
我沒說這件事不管付出多少代價都辦不到
他說這場美伊戰爭
剛好是 1991 年波灣戰爭的反面
那一仗美國用精準武器
一個多月就把伊拉克趕出鄰國科威特
全世界從此相信美軍打不敗
30 年後
又便宜又準的無人機從烏克蘭擴散到葉門
再到伊朗，他把這叫做第二次精準革命
最大的後果有這幾個
第一個，權力真空回來了
這是你們這一代得面對的問題
美國打不敗的形象
原本嚇阻了世界各地那麼多勢力
現在被打碎了
這代表那些地方的權力真空正在擴大
誰擋得住這些權力真空？
重點不在美國願不願意
兩、三個禮拜前，我人在歐洲議會
我們跟…我跟議員們談了兩個小時
本來是要談美伊戰爭
結果你知道嗎？變成在討論歐洲該拿烏克蘭怎麼辦
你知道我們沒談什麼嗎？
怎麼說服川普出手救歐洲。完全沒有
歐洲在意的已經不是美國的意願
因為歐洲學到的是，美國沒有這個能力
那是完全不同的一件事
如果歐洲人在烏克蘭這件事上已經這樣想
日本、南韓跟台灣也會這樣想
所以重點不是美國選擇不幫
而是全世界都不覺得我們幫得上忙
就算我們真的出手，他們也很怕越幫越忙
但最大的問題是，他們不覺得我們有這個能力
葉門有個武裝組織叫胡塞
伊朗在背後撐腰
9 月，胡塞拿下葉門整段紅海沿岸
紅海是亞洲貨船去歐洲最近的路
他說胡塞敢這樣做
就是因為美國已經嚇不住對手了
這波革命接下來還會在別的地方
讓全世界嚇一跳
我要給你們看的最大意外，跟中國和台灣有關
幾十年來，我們一直擔心中國入侵台灣、拿下台灣
有一個大家一直在推演的劇本，叫封鎖劇本
這個劇本我很熟，我上課就在教這個
所以我非常清楚。台灣是一座島
問題來了
第二次精準革命來了以後
如果我們連伊朗的無人機都打不贏
根本不可能對付得了中國的飛彈
各位，這不可能，就是不可能
可是這代表台灣只能孤軍奮戰、什麼都做不了嗎？
這就是…矛盾的地方
我要讓你們看到，我們確實救不了他們
可是台灣自己呢？
把台灣想成下一個伊朗
想像一下，台灣已經有 1 萬架無人機
用…台灣的無人機去打中國的港口
中國的港口
那些港口，中國 40% 的貿易…不對，是 GDP
幾乎所有的貿易、40% 的 GDP，都要經過那些港口
台灣的無人機打得到那些港口，就像伊朗的無人機打荷莫茲海峽的船
你不必派兵去占領港口
只要把船擊沉就好
船上都是平民，他們不會想送命
在未來的兩岸戰爭裡，這會大大扭轉局勢
那對我們代表什麼？
你可能會說，太好了，Pape 教授，那場仗我們不用打
我們少打一場仗。這部分是真的
可是這代表我們會吃到供應衝擊
你覺得荷莫茲海峽已經夠震撼了？
等中國的海運停擺 3 個月、6 個月再說
那會在我們國內掀起很大的連鎖效應
利率已經在漲了，這會讓它漲得更高
這就是我們接下來得面對的世界
我認為美伊戰爭對全球的影響，才剛開始
這就是我說的，你們這一代要面對的劇烈變動
抱歉，真希望我能帶來好一點的消息
照 Pape 的推論
轟炸跟封鎖都逼不垮伊朗
美軍打不敗的神話反而先碎了
下一場如果打在台灣海峽
他說美國救不了台灣
自己還會吃到供應衝擊
原影片一個多小時
問答時間他還擔心
美國的備用油庫已經吃緊
胡塞可能趁這時候卡住沙烏地阿拉伯從紅海運出去的油
他也估計
美伊戰爭演變成第三次世界大戰的機率
大約十分之一
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。